let's bring in the General Secretary of
the fire brigade Union should we uh Matt
Iraq hello to Mr rack thanks for joining
us on the program
um this morning what might your members
vote to strike over what's the problem
well we've had uh 12 years it's not just
this year it's since 2010 we've been
asked to pay the price for problems that
we didn't create so uh year on year
sometimes slightly above inflation but
generally below inflation and it's left
people uh in our service uh some 4 000
pounds a year as a minimum worse off
than if they're paid kept place with
inflation are staggering and you know
imagine the difference on someone's
living standards and ability to pay the
bills if they were four thousand pounds
a year better off and then this year we
have the the worst single uh pay cut
being proposed uh with uh the impacts on
our members being something like six
percent in a single year so our
firefighters and our members in
emergency fire controls have worked
throughout the pandemic we kept the fire
service going we all sorts of kind of
additional roles during that period and
our reward is to be told to tighten our
belts um and to struggle on and car
members are saying that that's not good
enough and therefore sadly we are
balloting for a strike
you've been offered five percent why is
that not enough
because 11 is the rate of inflation
currently so that's a six percent pay
cuts why should workers pay the price
for problems we didn't cause why should
firefighters and other public sector
workers and workers anywhere indeed be
told to take a pay cut what we've been
offered is actually a paid cuts and I
don't see how anyone justifies cutting
hay
because the country can't afford it at
the moment well that's nonsense isn't it
because some people have done very very
well there are people who've made
millions and millions in terms of covid
contracts you look at the profits of big
business you look at the very wealthy in
society the government could afford to
find 43 billion pounds just a few short
weeks ago in a handouts to the richest
people in society where they tell
workers that we've got to tighten our
belts and we've got people as your
introduction said now increasingly
unable to pay their bills firefighters
professionals delivering an essential
service being forced to food banks which
has been admitted by our employers and
by Chief officers I don't know how you
justify that how does anyone try to
justify that situation how worried are
you about the consequences for the
public if you do strike well obviously
we're very worried it's not a position
anybody wants to be in uh but equally
you can't go on year on year on year
being told to tighten your belts and
there's actually something will improve
somewhere down the line and it never
does improve So eventually you have to
take some action and that's what our
members are now deciding our members
have voted democratically to reject the
payoffer that they were made we're now
taking the next stage which is to ballot
them on Industrial action that's a very
sad thing to do none of our members want
to be in that position equally they've
got the problem of how do you pay the
bills how do you pay the rent the
mortgage the grocery bills the energy
bills at the end of the month
how effective is the Army when they are
brought in when you go on strike
well we haven't had the Army brought
into disputes
[Music]
that I that has not been discussed with
us uh Fire and Rescue Services are
required under the law to prepare
alternative arrangements for emergency
cover some of them have done that I
don't know what they have put in place
as I say that's not our responsibility
it's not responsibilities of our members
that's the responsibility of the
government but actually far better than
talking about whether the Army can
provide cover would be to sit down and
negotiate a a settlement on pay that
would avoid strike action in the first
place we wouldn't haven't we would not
be having to discuss that issue and do
you feel that your members would only
settle for an inflation busting pay rise
at this stage
well that's a democratic decision of our
members and that's the one on which I
wouldn't even have a vote our members
will decide that but I I had to ask why
should people be told to take a pay cut
is simply unreasonable you've got to pay
the bills aren't going down mortgages
are going up rents going up grocery
bills are going up energy bills are
going up why should your wages fall it
just does not make any sense it's unfair
it's unjust so uh I don't see why people
should be told to accept that and what
would you be advising your members
well we're advising our members to vote
Yes for industrial action so that we can
get in and talk to the government and to
our employers but the government hold
the purse strings here aren't they doing
many of the other disputes that you've
referred so uh what what lies behind
this is underfunding of the fire service
for 12 years and more where they have
slashed central government funding to
what is an essential service our members
go out every day of their lives to keep
people safe inspecting buildings making
sure the buildings and homes are safe
and obviously ultimately responded to
999 calls and putting their own personal
safety on the line and we do we believe
they deserve a professional rate of pay
for that and that's not what's happening
currently
foreign
okay it's uh good to talk to you this
morning just a thought before I let you
go
um last week I was talking to the nurses
Union they said that their members were
having to use food banks to get by week
to week what's the situation with your
members
yeah well this is quite a shock to us as
well we have uh we have a Chief Fire
officer actually went into one of our uh
the fire service magazines recently
announcing that he was aware of
firefighters in Avon who were having to
use food banks we've had reports from
our own Union officials around the
country of them having to sign to
authorize firefighters to attend food
banks I think it's something that will
be deeply shocking to many of our
members and to the public that people
undertaking a professional job like this
working longer hours and averaged or
42-hour week on shifts putting our
safety on the line as I've said can't
manage to pay the bills on their wages
and be enforced like many other people
to take to to use food banks is quite a
shocking State of Affairs in the fire
and rescue service and and I think
that's reflected in the anger that
people have and the frustration in the
failure of our employers and the
government to step in and resolve this
issue and we hope that that can still
happen before this ballot finishes in
January
okay thanks very much indeed thank you
thank you